oh
okay so yeah I'm super excited to
introduce Chris Manning as an expert
speaker who really doesn't need any
introduction whatsoever especially how
he has been among the most influential
figures across the Linguistics and NLP
field and then deep learning as well
um so he's going to talk about uh what
happens next with the llms
okay
um so I was somewhere
um between cajoled and inspired talking
to a mesh about higher level thoughts
about language and intelligence
um so I'm going to be taking rash moves
here since I decided that rather than
giving all of the talk I'd planned to
give here I'm just going to cut a lot of
it out and um redo
um a talk that I gave a year ago at cfar
which has some very speculative thoughts
on language and intelligence and that
might be fun so we'll see how that goes
okay but um let me um sort of tell the
big picture
um of the talk that you're only going to
see part of
um so what something that I've been
working on quite a lot with various
people including student Eric Mitchell
who'll be looking for a job and Chelsea
Finn is the idea that if we're going to
do more with language models that we
that a language model was like a car
engine but to actually have a car that
you can drive around you need all sorts
of things apart from the engine you need
Wheels but you need safety measures like
seat belts and airbags and you need all
sorts of other conveniences
um to make it possible and there's tons
and tons of interesting work in what's
needed for an ecosystem of Tools around
language models that make them effective
and safe
um so we know that large language models
are fascinating extremely good they
should have lots and lots of practical
use cases but in practice
they also have a lot of problems in
societal issues so there's problems with
keeping them up to date as the world
changes there's problems with getting
correct consistent non-hallucinated
answers out of them there's problems
with their use in society when people
are unhappy with the undetected use of
large language models and there's
problems with having them interact
um in appropriate ways with human beings
and so I think the situation we're still
in at the moment is kind of like this
um that um so Bloomberg fairly recently
um trained a pretty good large language
model Bloomberg GPT
um they trained it especially on
financial data and got good results from
doing that and showing it works much
much better on financial data than other
large language models and the question
is what are they doing with it and to a
first approximation the answer is
they're doing nothing with it because
um they still regard it as too risky to
let loose than any customer facing
application because who knows what it
might say at the wrong moment which is a
pretty serious issue if you're a company
um like Bloomberg so the only people are
actually using Bloomberg GPT at the
moment is researchers inside Bloomberg
and I think that's a sort of a fairly
large issue for a lot of us
um so we want to be working on how to
put in place this kind of guardrail
safety measures and guidance that'll
allow safe use of large language models
and I was going to present three pieces
of work
um to that topic but
um I'm going to make this up as we go
and I'm going to show the last one first
which is talking about a new way of
getting language models to learn from
Human feedback and we'll see how that
long that one takes and then I'll either
switch straight to the specular part or
maybe show a second thing so let's go to
this one
um yeah so this oh that's not the right
one that's not the one I wanted to go to
that was the second one
um
okay so in this part what I want to
present is direct preference
optimization which is a new algorithm
for learning from Human feedback so you
can think of it as an alternative to the
conventional kind of reinforcement
learning from Human feedback so it's
been so so Central to all of the large
language models that are in use today
um so as is well known pre-training
large language models on bulk text does
not naturally give a language model that
responds to user intent so that you give
it something like this is a bit small I
guess explain the moon landing to a
six-year-old in a few sentences and a
gpt3 model with just aside some random
pattern to explore and maybe it says
explain the theory of gravity as a
six-year-old explain the theory of
relativity to a six-year-old in a few
sentences what we'd like to get is
models
um which understand questions and
instructions as things to respond to
that gives us the kind of performance
that came out in the world with chat GPT
and well how can you do that well the
pioneering method to do that was this
method of reinforcement learning from
Human feedback and so let me just
briefly go over the pipeline of how
that's done so there are three stages so
the first step step is still General
well you start with a general
pre-trained large language model trained
on your trillion words of internet text
um and then what you're going to do
first is supervise fine tuning which is
simply doing more training to predict
the next word as you had before but
you're now training it on a particular
kind of text so you've collected
um text that is responses to human
demons human generated demonstrations
and instruction following tasks and you
fine-tune it to be better at following
that kind of text
so now you have something that sort of
knows how to respond to questions and
instructions
so the second step is we then sample
answers from the instruction tune model
typically to
um continuations for each instruction
and then we ask
um for feedback from human evaluators
and then the final step is tuning the
language model to human preferences
using reinforcement learning um this is
now what's widely referred to as
aligning your AI personally I'm not
actually that fond of that term
um
but um it's commonly used
okay so let me say that in just a little
bit more details what you do starting
with the step two part so the feedback
is you have a prompt two possible
answers sampled from your pre-trained
and unsupervised fine-tune model and
then you collect the human preferences
to which one of the two is better so I'm
going to use the notation where X is the
prompt the YW is the preferred response
the winner and the yl is the
dispreferred response that's the loser
um then the preference model is assumed
to follow the Bradley Terry model so
that there's some kind of score that can
be given to each pair of a prompt and a
response and then you're predicting
um the goodness by then sticking that
into the difference into a logistic
function and this gives a binary
probability
sort of and it's a little bit different
in its basis to be low but okay yeah
it's sort of similar yeah it's the same
model but it goes back to the early 50s
so I had another question like would you
regard these three components that just
logically separateful from each other
like you could do some without doing
others
I mean yeah I mean so
so supervised I believe in theory the
supervised fine-tuning should just be a
limitable and it'd make no difference to
how well it would work out though in
practice you know supervise fine-tuning
is a cheap way to get your language
model in the zone so you can collect
good data from which to start collecting
the rewards so if you didn't do the
super pies fine tuning you know you need
a hundred times thousand times I don't
know way more
um reward data and to do way more of the
reinforcement learning so you know
that's why that's there as I will
discuss uh more on some of the
experiments the supervised fine tuning
by itself just isn't enough that that
doesn't get you where you want to be so
you definitely um want the later phases
um
and then
they're sort of separate right yeah
you're a trainer award model and then
you're doing the reinforcement learning
based on that model and what I'm going
to show as a different approach which
more couples those two together
um okay so
um so what we do then is we train the
reward model so we the reward model is
going to be a neural network so it has
lots of parameters in particular the
standard thing is the reward model is
basically just a language model so the
standard thing you do is you take a
pre-trained language model and you Lop
off the very top where the soft mixes
are to produce words and you stick on a
single additional fully connected
um layer and then you train there and
that is your award model so you're
training this reward model is a neural
network to minimize negative log
likelihood unbirth the assumptions of
this Bradley Terry model of rating
preferences
okay so finally then we get to step
three so
we now have our parameterized reward
model that represents goodness according
to humans in terms of responses
um and so what we want to learn is a
policy
um which will achieve a high reward and
the way we're going to do that is we're
going to start with initial parameters
sample from the policy and then trying
to optimize over that policy to produce
a higher reward and standardly people
then always add the second term of
wanting to keep the model that you're
learning close to your original model
because all the preference data that
you've collected is
um on the original model so if you're
wandering too far away from that it's
then very unclear what you might do
um so you want to keep the safety of
your language model
um yeah so I'm not really much of a
reinforcement learning person
um so you know in my head what I'm
always thinking to myself is really this
is basically a language model with a
fully connected layer on top and this is
also a language model when you're
running these things in these systems
okay but crucially here in what you're
doing in this process it's offline
reinforcement learning over the
preference data you collected in the
second phase
and and what's parameterizing the space
of possible policies here
a Transformer
with an extra fully connected layer on
top
so so so for each such question the
answer is another transcript
questions
do the reward functions transfer
if I get a reward if I learn a reward
function for one particular model is it
going to transfer to another language
model
so
so the reward model should transfer
right because the reward model was just
having produced a model of what do
humans prefer so you should be able to
take your reward model and use that in
the reinforcement learning phase with
any language model
the the other question very quickly and
you've said a lot you know you do this
you do that or this is what is done
how standard is this
I mean I think this is what everybody
does so this was the process of an
instruct gbt that was
um pioneered
um at open AI
um similar stuff then happened at Google
you know like there's some people have
played with variants a bit of sort of
different
um reinforcement learning methods but
you know I guess what instruct GPT did
work so successfully that my impression
is basically everyone has copied it with
pretty much this recipe
okay
um yes oh
Yeah you mentioned that the reverse
model is just a pre-trained model with
an another layer on top like so does
that mean that but you but you train the
whole thing so it's not frozen so when
you hit the pre-trained model like it's
from the so you originally just
talking to myself yeah so that's
so so short answers maybe yeah that's a
that's a part where there's some
variation and some fun and games that
people can do I mean because sometimes
people don't fully separate them they
actually keep the low levels of that the
language models shared so it becomes a
sort of funny kind of
um multi-task learning but um maybe we
can kind of leave out some of those
details here and just think that you
have you can either have multiple copies
or you could use different language
models it doesn't even have to be the
same one
okay
um so then you go into the reinforcement
learning stage so um the standard
um thing that people have used is PPO
because that's what John Shulman did at
open Ai and it seemed to work well but
in general you're wanting to use some
actor critic
um reinforcement learning algorithm
um so just sort of like two weeks ago
um this paper came out of Secrets of
rohf and large language models part one
PPO and this is
um I think this is the kind of diagram
that you provide if you don't want
people to understand it's nothing more
um and I'm I'm not going to go through
this diagram
um what I'm hoping you'll take away from
this diagram is you know although PPO
can achieve good results it's actually
pretty complex it's potentially unstable
for some elements of its design and it
takes lots of computational resources
um to be running it so what I'm hoping
to to tell you about today is this work
that a bunch of us have done recently at
Stanford on coming up with a more
straightforward we hope alternative
called direct preference optimization
okay that so that was the background is
everyone roughly good on the background
yeah okay so the idea of direct
preference optimization is that if we
parameterize our our reward model
correctly differently we can extract the
optimal policy from our learned reward
model with no additional training I we
don't have to do the same kind of
um actor critic reinforcement learning
process so we don't have all of the
complexity
um from that previous diagram and so
rather than the traditional
reinforcement learning pipeline that's
been used in our lhf where you collect
the preference data based on that you
train a reward model by maximum
likelihood and then you do this
iterative process of sampling
completions from
your model
um
scoring um
scoring them with the rewards and then
sort of trying to use PPO to improve how
well you perform that we're going to
have a direct correspondence between the
reward model and the optimal policy and
because of that we can have this much
simpler process where we just have
preference data and then do a maximum
likelihood
learning process to get our final
language model and our final language
model will indeed be the optimal
language model relative to our reward
function and the way that I will explain
as we go on and so the question then is
how we can go about doing that sorry
model does that also include minimizing
the distance
yes
yeah so that's part of the optimization
okay
so we start with exactly the same rlhf
objective as before so yeah here's the
answer to your question same objective
we're wanting to maximize so
um right so for our data set preference
data set
um that we collected for each X
um and then drawing you know y's from
our policy and working out to reward we
want to maximize the reward and then
subject to this same constraint of
wanting to stay close um to the base
model
okay
um note that this expression works for
any reward function so it doesn't have
any requirement that it's connected to
our PPO
um so it turns out that in general just
given the expression above
um you can work out
um in close form and optimal policy for
um the
reward function so it's just something
that was actually shown by people in
Sergey was in screws up at Berkeley a
few years ago
um and it's not actually that difficult
you do a sort of a the usual bits of
algebra and math and introduce you know
your season one on Z's and
um you can rearrange it into this form
so the optimal policy is proportional to
the base model weighted by some function
of the reward and remember that our base
model Pi ref that's our large language
model that's been fine-tuned um with the
supervised fine-tuning
okay
um the problem here is we've still got
this Z term which is the sum over every
possible response
um to
um your instruction and so this is
um makes the valid probability
distribution that makes it
um not possible to just go ahead and
compute Earth because it's intractable
to work with
um exactly
and that's something that we then sort
of work out a way to work out our way
around so doing an even more trivial bit
of algebra you can
um just rearrange this
um so that you have want the expression
of what the reward is and so the reward
is then going to be beta times the log
of the ratio of the probability of the
of the optimal policy over the reference
policy plus beta times the log of the
normalization term and so this ratio is
positive if the policy likes the
response more than the reference model
and negative the policy like the
response less than the reference model
okay so this is our general
reparameterization
um and so it's sort of giving us the
expression for the reward function the
policy is optimal
but sorry the reward function the policy
is optimal for can be expressed as a log
probability ratio between the policy and
the reference model plus some function
yeah
I mean here the normalization terms he
is still intractable and does depend on
the reward function that it's only a
function of the prompt it's not a
function of what we generate and so the
key idea of DPO is we're going to train
our policy such that the reward function
is optimal for given this equation
agrees with human preferences according
to Bradley Terry
I mean so in other words we're just
going to stick this equation into the
Bradley Terry loss
so we have a loss function on reward
functions a transformation between
reward functions and policies and that's
going to give us a loss function on
policies okay so here is our Bradley
Terry loss model of human preferences
here's what we just produced as the
reward as a function of the policy and
then we just plug those two things
together and now we have a loss function
that we can evaluate in terms of
policies and here the very nice thing
happens that these two terms the same
and they cancel out when you subtract
them and so now we've gotten rid of the
nasty Z term
um so that's cool
um
and so the train model
that is
this will give us a train model which
will have a policy that will be optimal
for the reward function that aligns with
human preferences so the model that
optimizes the DPO loss is the optimal
model
um minimizing the Bradley Terry loss so
the only thing we've effectively changed
is we have a different architecture for
the reward function and so once we do
normal reward learning we'll be able to
extract the optimal policy in closed
form
um so one thing that you could worry
about is well we've sort of changed the
architecture in terms of neural terms or
the form of
um what we're working with so is it
possible that the way we're expressing
the reward model in terms of the
language model somehow affects what
kinds of rewards we can learn and so
um the clever students
um proves some theorems showing that
under fairly mild assumptions that all
reward classes that consistent with
Bradley Terry losses can be represented
in terms of this reparameterization of
the reward in terms of a ratio of
policies which are themselves language
models of the kind that we're using here
and I'm not going to go through that
either but you may find in section five
of the paper
okay but what I will show you is some
experiments
um so um here's just some URLs of code
um this is our own implementation of
this
um but then I spoke and hugging face
have already released a version of it um
that appears in the their Transformers
reinforcement learning library so the
first experiment is a kind of a toy
experiment so this is
um generating synthetic text to give a
very positive movie review so we've got
IMDb movie reviews and we're going to
use as the prompt the first handful of
words of the movie review and we're
going to say generate more text and we
want you to write a very positive movie
review no matter what the first five
words say and for the reward of the
movie reviews we're going to use an
off-the-shelf sentiment classifier so
our gold standard and what we can use
the sort of as a reward model is this
um pre-trained sentiment classifier
um and so we then use that pre-trained
Quest sentiment classifier to judge
between Pairs of generations when doing
reward training
um and then we can compare optimization
with either PPO or DPO and in the PPO
case we also consider both that learning
the reward model from the preference
data or just using the gold reward model
which is given to us by our sentiment
classifier
um and so this then
um Compares a whole bunch of results so
where these results come is from each
method we did four training runs and we
stopped it at various
um checkpoints and so for each of those
things we could see how high is the
average reward it's getting for the
generation and how far away
um the Learned policy is from the
starting off language model and so if we
sort of start at the bottom
so one thing you could do is just use
the data of what is the preferred forms
and do more supervised fine-tuning on
that so you're sort of learning to that
the positive examples are good and
that's where really this just isn't very
effective that you sort of basically no
matter how how near or far you are from
the reference language model you're
getting a reward of about 0.6 in green
um then the next thing we did was
running the hugging face Transformers RL
Library running their implementation of
PPO and that's somewhat better it's
starting to learn a better
um average reward of almost 0.8 as it
moves further away from the reference
model
um playing around with this sum we sort
of found that the hugging face PPO
implementation or at least the hyper
parameters and schedules that it came
with not really the core code
um didn't actually seem that great
um so we fiddled around with PPO some
and so for our version of it we're then
into this one and it's learning much
better it's getting up to about 0.9
reward usually that sort of starts to
Trend down over here in a couple of
samples which maybe I'll come back to
later now both of these are just using
the supervised model the gold standard
for the reward as the reward and not
actually learning the reward but then
for these pinkish ones here we're doing
the sort of the full standard pipeline
we're both learning the reward from the
preference data and we're running the
PPO algorithm and that behaves basically
exactly the same maybe fractionally
better over here
um
um then the final line here
um is unlikelihood training which is an
algorithm that's been proposed and in a
way is not completely dissimilar
um to the method that we use in DPO in
that you're wanting to you know be the
good stuff is being made likely
um the bad stuff is being made unlikely
but it doesn't have the same kind of
scaling of examples that's used in the
DPO method and so then over here and
also it's quite unstable right sometimes
it works great and sometimes it works
much less well then up here is the DPO
examples and so where you'd like to be
is up in the top left corner you'd like
to get high reward and you'd like to not
have the language model move too far
away from the the base language model
because you know as a language model
something that produces language just
like humans do the base language model
is essentially perfect they tried it's
the one that's this extremely well
calibrated probabilistic model
um and so you're able to get extremely
high reward without moving very far away
um from the base language model and its
performance is extremely stable it
doesn't vary much between runs do you
have a sense as to why Enlightenment
training is unstable I would have
thought that it I mean it
incorrectly you're just increasing the
probability of the good stuff and
decreasing I'm building the bad stuff
there's no RL so I wouldn't have
expected it to be unstable
um
I know that's not what you're actually
getting to talk about yeah
I'm not really sure if I do
which
uh maybe helps to stabilize the learning
yeah in the original on likelihood you
may not be doing tail term and I don't
know whether you necessarily added at
all right yeah I think I have to put all
sort of pass on that one too is I'm not
100 sure but I think maybe the other
part of it is is the unlikelihood
training does not provide the same kind
of waiting over examples as to which
examples are important to modulate how
you change the parameters and that might
be much less stable because in DPO
you're sort of feeding things into the
logistic form of the Bradley Terry loss
which means it means that sort of
they're examples where you learn a lot
where you want to differentiate between
things that are apart but not too far
apart and they're examples where you
learn very little once you're into the
sort of flat parts of the logistic and I
think that might be part of as well but
um not 100 sure
okay so can we do
um slightly
um more um real world experiments than
that
um yeah so this
um experiment is on um Reddit tldr
summarization so you're starting off
with a prompt of something so this is
sort of embedded in one of these
experiment frames of
um you know which of the following
summaries does a better job at
summarizing here's the post here summary
a summary B give a judgment but the
prompt is
um the summer the thing to summarize you
know as some Reddit post I've been
ungrateful to parents who've only wanted
the best for me for the longest time I'm
so lucky it'll have the life I have but
I have squandered it I'm 17 leaving for
University and I've had an epiphany
um and so the job of both of these
models is to summarize this post and DPO
came up with I've been a shitty child
and I want to make up for it what can I
do for my parents on their birthdays and
Christmas to show them how much I love
them now you know we're not actually
explicitly in the algorithm comparing
the output of DPO and PPO but you know
here's just a fun example where we did
it with PPO as well and PPO said I've
been a shitty person to my parents what
can I do to make it up to them that
part's very similar before I go and what
can I do after University to make them
happy and what can I do to make them
happy after University if that is the
case and so then we wanted to judge
which one of these things when we had
two answers from the same model were
better and what we used to give
judgments primarily
um was gpt4 very scalable modulo the
money and gpt4 said about these two
summary B which is the DPO one in this
case because they're randomly ordered
more effectively captures the main
points of the post by focusing on making
the parents happy through gestures on
special occasions or while summary a
seems repetitive and less clear
preferred B
um and so here is sort of what we're
going to do here is we're going to
compare the summarization win rates of
different
um learned
policies learned rlhf models
um
compared to human written summaries
using gpt4 as the evaluator and one
other parameter we can vary for
Generation which has already come up is
the temperature at which we're doing
generation and optimal temperatures vary
um somewhat with methods though it seems
like
um for the rlhf methods generally very
low temperature they're so fairly
deterministic one seems to perform worse
um so certainly for PPO it performs
pretty well at low temperatures and
really Falls away at high temperatures
DPO performs better than PPO which is
why I put the slide up of course but
it's also falls away less badly
um this best of 128 is sort of a crude
but effective method which is you
generate
128 different possible answers you score
them all by the reward model and you
just take the best one so if you run
sort of
best of for a large enough K that
actually proves here quite um effective
method of finding a good answer
um let's see this is the base language
model we're using gptj and simply using
supervised fine tuning again doesn't
work very well
okay
um so that makes it look good of course
this is um oh sorry I should have said
um you know
this is against human written summary so
anything above 0.5 means that
um gpt4 is preferring the model's output
to the human summary and so we we have
um the better than human summarizes here
since a lot of these results are getting
about 60 percent being chosen by dpt4 of
course you might just worry that gpd4s
are very bad evaluator
um so we did a smaller study that um
then looked at humans so this is taking
two of the models
um DPO and then one of the poorly
performing ones the supervised
fine-tuning and
um it's comparing both of them to PPO at
zero which also performed well and
saying what win rate
um do you give to these models and so
supervised fine-tuning mostly loses to
PPO but DPO according to gpd41 54 of the
time it's a little bit better at
temperature zero but the human said that
DPO won 58 of the time
um so
um
from this it seems that
um you know humans and gpt4 ratings are
fairly similar and if anything the
humans seems are slightly more
um prefer what you're getting out of um
DPO
um it's also the case
um this is sort of that a human agreeing
with gpt4 is again basically the same
with humans agreeing with each other
um so that it seems like you know
basically
um gpg4 judgments seem as good as human
judgments in this circumstance
um one more real world example
um so anthropics released this
helpfulness harmlessness data set where
you know the prompt here is I'm trying
to locate the residential address for JB
pritzky an area of a Hyatt Hotel fortune
and you know the um harmless answer is
to say naughty naughty I'm not meant to
be telling you um the private addresses
of
um famous people and so we're evaluating
on that data set
um and again
we're comparing
um to a sort of a human one and looking
at our win rates
um
so again we're able to see that we're
able to get about a 60 win rate
um from DPO
um on this data set
um we actually weren't able to get PPO
working on this data set so I can't
compare it against PPO
um but I've got best 128 and it's
certainly again working much better than
preferred fine tuning
um so just one final point on this is I
mean some an empirical phenomenon has
been noted is that at some point if you
keep on optimizing your your award and
doing your PPO
um so so PPO load reward model you tend
to get to the point where that it thinks
the reward is going continuing to go up
but according to the true reward model
actually your performance is going down
um so that's been
um loaded in this Alpaca Farm paper by
some of our standard Stanford colleagues
it's also been replicated synthetic
settings and open at open Ai and so you
might thought that we'd suffer worse
from that problem because after all
we've come up with this clever
reprioritarization so that you're
actually completely optimizing the
policy for the reward board but it's
actually you know
we can't say that that wouldn't happen
eventually but it just doesn't seem to
happen badly to the the length that
we've um done fine tuning for quite a
while
um that you're not seeing anything sort
of Falling Away badly
okay so DPO allows you to express the
reward model simply in terms of the
language model itself and so you can
fine-tune the language model on
preference data directly without having
to do this kind of introvert
reinforcement learning training Loop and
so DPO gives us simple apparently quite
stable and computationally much cheaper
way to do reinforcement learning with
human feedback
and it's optimizing the same kind of
objective and performs very well so make
your life simple try using DPO when you
want to fine-tune from Human preferences
okay so that's the end of that and I'll
now switch horses and same my very
speculative part on language
here we go
all right
okay
um this talk is at this
these slides at this point historical
since I gave them
um in October 2022 at a cfar meeting so
crucially the thing to remember which is
really hard to remember these days is
um Chachi PT is less than a year old in
fact it's just coming up for its nine
month adversary
um in a few days time
um so chat GPT
um had not yet come out at the time I
gave this talk
um since it came out about a month and a
half later
um so
um it's not going to have the very
latest examples about it but let me
mainly for sort of 10 or so minutes um
concentrate on the high level part
um so what I want to do is sort of
introduce this idea of a Von Humboldt
machine the idea that we're sort of
moving into this phase of neural
networks that use symbols and language
to build their intelligence it's a
purely speculative talk but hopefully
good for
um thinking here so my dear colleague
um Jan McCune and Jake Browning a
philosopher have been involved in
writing a sequence of articles for the
journal no email so the first one they
wrote was what AI can tell us about
intelligence and you know I really
really like that one it kind it clearly
and
um
balanced the in my exp feeling
contrasted you know the two main views
of symbols is where they're hard-coded
at the outset which is kind of a Chomsky
and view of language and intelligence or
whether they can be learned through
experience and argued well for the
latter
um and
so I said I like that hey
um but you know
um a few months after that they produced
another piece of noema which was called
Ai and the limits of language and that
one I thought was kind of misguided
um so um this um these slides are sort
of my response to thoughts on reading
the this Browning and lacoon piece so
these are some of the things that they
say
um large language models understanding
of language while impressive is shallow
um
abandoning The View that all knowledge
is linguistic permits us to realize how
much of our knowledge is non-linguistic
non-linguistic mental simulation and
animals and humans is common and useful
for planning out scenarios and can be
used to craft or reverse engineer
artifacts a system trained on language
alone will never approximate human
intelligence even if it is trained from
now until the heat death of the universe
as you can see they have some fairly
strongly held views about the limits of
language
um
and
I think there's sort of uh
ending up sort of
arguing against uh a false position
um where they claim that wanting to try
and say is that people believe that
language exhausts knowledge that the
only knowledge
um that exists is language where I don't
think even the strongest proponent of
language
would say that language exhausts
knowledge you know even though Chomsky
knows that when he sticks his hand under
the water it feels hot or cold and
that's not really linguistic
um
so I think in making this kind of
argument that they actually end up as
false prophets because they've sort of
been too scared of all the things that
um Gary Marcus writes and so it's then
leading them to take a rather
ridiculously strong position in Reverse
indeed one of the sections of their
papers is titled exercising the ghost
um and so that leads them to be sort of
making these kind of false claims where
they're failing to recognize how
important language is to human
intelligence
um they make other false claims as well
um I don't know maybe education is very
different in France I was having a
conversation with chefies of how more
rigorous education in other countries
um but they claim while science classes
do have a lecture component students are
graded primarily based on their lab work
I don't know what educations other
people had but I have never done a
science class that was primarily graded
based on its lab work
um
and well we've already I've already read
oh yeah and then there's this bit they
say language is important because it can
convey a lot of information in a small
format and especially after the creation
of the printing press
um and the internet can involve
reproducing and making it available
widely so I think this is a very common
error and it's certainly
um the error of
um Jan mccoons position that he feels
that the only roles of language are
compressing your knowledge and allowing
it being communicated to other human
beings and communication of ideas so
that they're not one individual's head
but are spread across board spread
across Humanity that actually has been
an important idea that's Advanced
Humanity a lot and you know having
printing in the internet that's Advanced
Humanity a lot but I think there's just
more to it right so humans
and many of the elements of human-like
intelligence you know it's not that
different from other animals right the
things that we talk about for human
intelligence you know memory planning
cause and effect reasoning tool use
compound tool construction
um you know all of those things are also
things that are observed in animals
um and you know for higher animals like
chimpanzees right there brains are
basically homologous to ours and even
you know areas that the primary language
areas like Brokers areas right
chimpanzees have broken areas
um and so you know people have observed
how um chimpanzees will use their tools
use their sticks to get the ants out of
a hole and then there's instruction
because one chimp will teach the little
chimp um how to go about doing it and if
we watch the video for longer then the
other little chimps going to have a go
so it's learning by instruction just
like human beings but it turns out you
don't need as something as clever as a
chimp you can have something like with a
microscopic brain like a crow in
particularly all of these experiments
are done with Southern Hemisphere crows
I think somehow southern hemisphere
crows are more intelligent than Northern
Hemisphere crows I'm not sure of the
details of that but you know crows in
the Pacific
um you know really they can do all the
same stuff
um that you can
um stick food in Holes the crow can't
reach it with its beak it can go off and
find
still not reaching it it can then
um find a stick and then it can get bits
of food out with a stick it puts the
stick down it realizes it won't balance
so it puts its foot on it it's planning
ahead do you know it understands all of
this stuff right
um so you know kind of intelligent
um but you know we sort of have this
difference that the limit of tool use by
animals is sort of a few crude sticks
and we human beings have rather better
tools
um
and so Wilhelm Von Humboldt was this
kind of interesting German dude
um he is he's two um American grad
schools has essentially attributed to
the idea that was invented in Germany
um but he mainly worked on language
um he's a favorite of Noam chomsky's who
always quotes
um his
um statement that human language must
make infinite use of finite means he's
used that as the justification for the
kind of universal grammar that he's
worked on but he said a lot of other
things people can find lots of things in
Humboldt's writings including some quite
racist things actually which I won't get
into today
um but one of his Central ideas was that
language is not merely an outward
manifestation of thought for the purpose
of communication so one of the things he
said is language is not product I ergon
but an activity in a gear and so
effectively he distinguishes from what
we tend to call now it's so system one
cognitive Mission from system to
thinking and he sort of Saw language as
this an extent a central part of being
able to extend the mind to allow system
to thought
um so mental activity which which
produces the expression of thought this
is this higher system to thought is
always directed upon language already
given
um it is not purely creative but a
reshaping activity and that language is
the necessary foundation for the
progress of the human mind we can debate
how totally true that is but it sort of
seems to be true
um so Daniel Dennett in this book from
bacteria to bark and back
um that it's primarily about
Consciousness but in the course of that
book he introduces sort of four levels
of
um intelligences and so this is getting
to levels of intelligences that we're
talking about in the morning so the
lowest level is darwini in which is your
pre-designed fixed competence doesn't
improve in your lifetime so that you
only get Improvement by Evolution so
that's things like bacteria and viruses
the next level up is Canarian
intelligence so that's when you can do
reinforcement learning
um the classic scenarian rewards and
learn to get the rewards the third level
of intelligence is then preparing
intelligence and so preparing
intelligence is when you build a model
of the environment and so then you can
do offline testing of plans with your
environment model and it seems like
already crows can achieve this level of
preparing intelligence
um and then the fourth level of denit
distinguishes is Gregorian intelligence
and David argues that the essence of
Gregorian intelligence is that you can
build tools that magnify your thinking
so language just one tool that magnifies
your thinking but then it argues that
other tools that magnify human thinking
include mathematics
computers but also democracy that
democracy has been a way of building a
tool to improve our thinking
and Danica argues that um human beings
are the only biological examples of
Gregorian intelligence
and so what it seems like we're doing
now is that we're seeing in these recent
um language models that we have now
starting to have machines that have
Gregorian intelligence that they can
build their own tools
these examples now are kind of old
because they're in the structure GPT era
but precisely once we started doing the
instruction fine-tuning rather than just
seeing sort of arbitrary completions
from gpt3 we can have language starting
to be manipulated as a tool inside these
models
I might skip a few of the other examples
because they're getting old now but you
know what we've starting to discover now
is that we can sort of do so much with
these language models by regarding them
as have building and using Thinking
Tools
um so
um
an interesting guy who's become a sort
of a hit sensation on the internet
lately as this guy Riley Good Side
um who's sort of become
um the the prophet of how to write
complex prompts which get your models to
do wonderful things he's got an
interesting history he used to work on a
dating sites he used to work at OkCupid
and Grindr but now he is the sort of
um the the true prophet of how to prompt
your large language models to do
interesting things
um and so the kind of oops sorry I have
this bit here the kind of thing he's
worked out how you can do is you are
gpt3 if you can answer directly use this
format if you're not able to answer what
you should do is consult IPython use
this format to send stuff to IPython and
then get the answer and sort of this
kind of complex instructions and use of
tools
um you then build up enormously what you
can get your language model to do
because it can call out try Python and
then it can multiply numbers
um completely correctly
so you know for most of the history of
deep learning and its Resurgence you
know people believe that gradient-based
learning was the answer to everything
and the question was you know how to
extend that to higher forms of cognition
but I think that's actually maybe now
seeming wrong the gradient-based
learning
is the right answer for type 1 cognition
but to really reach type 2 cognition
maybe the right answer is constructing
Gregorian Thinking Tools and effectively
some of what we're now seeing at open
ail square is the construction of
Gregorian Thinking Tools where the
language model is then making use of a
calculator or calling out to some other
device
and so we're entering this world where
language is a mechanism of instruction
but also a mechanism of thinking and
thinking over symbolic language actually
enables higher level thought and the
form of cognitive Improvement in the
same way it has for human beings versus
chimpanzees and crows thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh super interesting talk I have a
question about the DPO which um
since Dawson that preference data is all
given up reality
um so it's a more offline whereas bpoi
prism can be more online so depending on
the quality of a preference data that
EPO began with uh I wonder if there can
be a difference and during college so
when you say it's optimal I suspect that
it has to do with some assumption about
the preference the data that you're
given yes yeah yeah sure sure right so
yeah so a perfectly good yeah that's a
perfectly good objection is to say well
wait a minute yeah
that there are some advantages to really
doing reinforcement learning
um
and so you are right
um you know but as I understand it the
way everyone is doing rlhf they're doing
it based on offline reinforcement
learning where he is the big pile of
preference data learn on that
um and so you know if you remember you
know
um your opening reinforcement learning
lectures where you've got the agent
wandering around in the little Micro
World and learns as it's going that's
not actually what they're doing right
they've just got this training set and
they're saying let's run a reinforcement
learning algorithm on it but you could
feel that yeah well wait a minute as
you're sort of learning and veering away
if you can then be
collecting more on policy data than that
would help you and yeah that's possible
it's not what's standardly being done I
guess the question then is you know
whether you can get the kind of
um preference data to go with it right
because at that point there have been
are two possibilities one possibility is
well maybe you can get some value with
unsupervised on policy
um reinforcement learning and maybe that
could be a possible
strategy that's not very clear where
that's going to work at all since it
really seems like the contrast of
learning between having good and bad has
driven all of this but otherwise this
has only become relevant if you are
somehow collecting here are two possible
responses which one do you like more
human maybe kind of like in web search
results I mean of course to the extent
that you collected that data you can
then also put in the pile for further
offline and reinforcement learning
of his last stage with
Thinking Tools if I think about say like
how we built computers it seems like to
build a computer we had to build kind of
all these other engines of production
like we need to do design silicon uh
there's kind of all these like economic
uh just like physical tools
and like um that maybe isn't showing up
the thing
without and so I'm wondering if you
think that stage is also unfortunate if
so how it kind of fits into this picture
I haven't really thought about
um mining silicon but you know I do I do
believe that we need stuff that isn't
language models you know I'm I'm with
you Jan McCune insofar as saying oh we
should actually have decent models of
the 3D world I mean you know I think
we're at an interesting point right at
the moment right so basically lots and
lots of
um roboticists are now making use of
large language models
um in their robotic system and that's
because of the crazy reason that once
you move outside of just sort of the
things that a traditional physics engine
can do you know movement with rigid
objects
um the language models are actually a
better world model than anything else
anybody has but you know on the other
hand they're really lousy World models
in sort of the details compared to the
kind of I think you know 3D World
understanding that we have so yeah I
think there are a lot of other things
that you need as well
but you know part of that is learn to
mix and shared through language right
in terms of the ability
not sure to be honest Maybe
I mean the temperature is sort of a
separate parameter I'm not quite sure
it's over the temperatures and then if
you always trying to be more
another question is the multimodality
would start at um any explanation or
description to the language of human
I'm sure I mean
so I think this is
I mean I think most humans have the
intuition that all the other stuff
um of what they've seen and smelt and
felt is really really important I mean
you know I think
in terms of what's happened in the last
five years
um the surprising thing has been in the
other direction has I think blown our
minds as to how much you can do with
language alone because it turns out that
the even for things that seem very
physical there's just lots and lots of
language you can find in books web pages
Etc that talk about the fields of things
and describes what they look like and
you can do an amazing amount of language
only these things but you know it's
still just very incomplete so yes sure
you need to also have more
so maybe just one last question
the question was
um is there something like uh and uh
halfway point towards John's position
right he also believes in RL or
interaction with the world is kind of
important and do you think that
something like RL is also an important
component of actually teaching events
so yes I do
um yeah
um
so
I mean it's hard to know this for sure
right because I mean you know I think
it's just been unexpectedly good what
you've been able to achieve with huge
language models trained on one trillion
plus words you know I think all the all
the theory of child psychology and human
language
um
acquisition says that just shouldn't be
possible that interaction is clearly
just hugely hugely important for human
development of both language and
cognition
um
you know but it seems like somehow it
turns out that if you instead substitute
well you know we're now up to about a
hundred thousand times as much data as a
little human
um sees that you can do a very good job
of Learning Without interaction and I
guess the question is is that still up
fundamentally up abounded in some ways
show that interaction improving oh yeah
well I mean for humans there are times
but language models yeah I think it's
not quite so clear right
oh okay so since then we have to take
the rest of the questions offline
[Applause]